did I scare you high rejection it's your girl
Sally AKA Sally lomonaco AKA salamander I am at
Sally Lamonica on all of my socials go subscribe
to my channel but before you do that subscribe to
this one today we are watching Insidious I don't
do while watching scary movies alone I love a good
scary movie but alone not a fan I'm excited and
not excited I would like to sleep tonight scary
movies they're like a guilty pleasure I enjoy the
idea of watching them and then when I am watching
them I tend to not finish them you can blame
Greg if I pick my pants anyway please leave a
like on this video if at any point you Vibe with
me and you're like yes Queen same I remember when
this movie first came out I believe I was like in
high school and everyone was like dude Insidious
it's crazy and I was like yeah I'm good I'm
good so click that notification Bell if you
want to check out more reactions from me Greg or
John all also please check out the patreon it's
patreon.com the real rejects they are going to
put to my full reaction if you want to sit and
have the full experience with me like little movie
date you can't grab my hand if you get scared you
have to sync up with your own copy though again
patreon.com the real rejects let's just do it rip
off the payday salary also thanks to prepper for
editing together these highlights three two one
oh
girl no stop stop stop oh my God
that was not necessary just saying
Why do ghosts like moving
pictures it's so annoying uh
I hate dolls I can't I can't look at it
this is just the freaking opening credits
um
hey sweetie oh she's matching show me a
picture where Dad was a little kid and
I wish I could but I don't think we have
any he's really hopeless at keeping photos
every time I think I've pulled you out I crawl
back in he's like Chris Pratt with more hair
don't like that I've been like oh it's
just the kids right the kids are reading
foreign
sounds like the toilet why would you put
an infant on like the second floor um
scary
I can't do this
it's just a ladder
it's always the heater why is it always the heater
oh it's just the heater making the noise all right
nope
why would you go up there why would you do it what
is the re why it just closed the door crazy kid
asking for it go downstairs
I don't want to be up here
okay
ow
en
what happened did you fall did you fall off
the ladder how did you fall down yeah what
were you doing okay yeah he may be a superhero
buddy but you're not invincible you got to be
careful all right okay um I think I have a couple
of good songs I mean not all of them but I think
I love all your stuff shut
up you do not stop it cute
I don't know what that was can
you go wake up dogs and Josh
oh no hey sleepy pads you better get out of
that bed your mother's gonna kill us both
did he get a concussion Dalton don't don't Dalton
there's no brain damage that we've detected
there's gotta be something I'm sorry just
stay here we'll conduct some further testing
it's only been a couple of days it could take a
little longer it's like every parent's nightmare
oh
girl go get your baby
go get your baby
I want it I got it I want it I get it
stop looking at things oh my God I'm scared mom
me too boy I'm scared of what
don't do can I change rooms
why would you want to change rooms I
don't like when he walks around at night
listen um back to the hospital with you it's
probably just interference those things are
always picking up somebody else's I don't
know it sounded so clear it scared the hell
out of me and I was at the piano and you
could hear it on the Monitor and I turned
I would have called my husband at work
and be like [__] get home right now
oh my God I hated that I hate
these headphones now stop
hello
oh my God you're crying okay
I hate you oh my God [__]
there's nobody here I saw someone
bring the crab in your room Jesus
stop there can't be another jump scare this
early [__] oh my God call the cops stop
stop get in an Airbnb or something
unnecessary
see you tomorrow
wait is that the saw guy on the chalkboard is
that jigsaw on the chalkboard it is hey honey
it's me um Dave just told me I've got to uh I
gotta I'm gonna have to stay late tonight to uh
I gotta grade some tests no you need to get home
to your wife no you need to get home to your wife
hmm
how did the nurse not ice that oh
no
bye moving honey we're going we're going
I'm scared of this house it's like a sickness
ever since we've moved and everything's just
gone wrong you think our house is haunted
I don't think it I know at the time yes
fine deal with this
oh he's on my couch I don't care if I'm mad at you
you're sleeping in the bed with me
because I'm not gonna get murdered
same
no
oh yeah oh Jesus
good job no that's not your husband idiot
maybe if he slept in the bed with hmm
oh that means the Slytherin
interesting so they do move but
like that like never happens
until the end I can't believe you got Josh
to hold still for a photo not me or anybody
knows what you're going through right now
whatever you have to do to get through it do it
and you don't have to apologize
for anything she's very intense
oh my God was that a child
foreign
came from
um
oh no
child no stop laughing
stop it
I'm good
dolphin that's not Dalton you idiot
gotta be crying too it's a lot of
money to get a third house last night I
went into Dalton's room there was something in
there with it it was standing there in the corner
no I asked it who are you and it said
The Visitor I said what do you want
stop it said Dalton
still hear that voice
oh Jesus
Greg
piss myself
oh my God I know someone who can help
if you're willing to ask
why are you so skeptical excuse you where
is Elise she sent us ahead to do something
help sweet out the nut jobs
oh great here comes another drink
I really don't like this I'm Josh I knew
that I've grown since I last saw you
last saw me your mother and I
have been friends a long time
so this thing happened to him as
a kid but that was the flashback
what is it
stop I don't want to see it I
just want to see the drawing
stop stop how do I see it I said I don't see it
it's your son I don't understand have
you ever heard of astral projection um
he has you see these are people with the ability
to leave their physical body and to travel to
different places in astral form and it's that very
lack of fear that has led him to travel too far
and to become lost in a place that
I call the further is a Dark Realm
filled with the tortured Souls of the
Dead a place not meant for the living
there are entities that know this because they
can smell it that's why they're gathered around
them they're all trying to get inside of his
physical body simply because they they crave life
I'm gonna head out I can't have somebody coming
into our home and telling us that the reason
our son is in a coma is because his soul is
floated off somewhere in another dimension
we're gonna bring her all the way here and not
even consider what she's saying I did this to
make sure you could feel at ease don't Gaslight
her not to believe anybody you don't believe me
but this this is dangerous you guys
lighting your gaslighting you know it's true
you're telling me they move houses
and hung these up on the wall come on
okay
look scary can you hear us answer us
where are you I don't understand follow my
voice Dalton why aren't you talking anymore
if they hear me they'll hurt me who
will hurt you who will hurt you Dalton
I don't like it helps
is she good bro is she possessed now
what foreign
oh no
turn down the lights
three cameras Around the Clock we got nothing
I mean it got nothing that was insane
I was like holy no worries oh my
gosh friend my friend my friend bro
no Mom what are you doing here I asked your mother
to come over I called her immediately after the
session why there's something we must talk about
my husband was possessed at what point hmm it's
no accident that your son is a gifted Traveler
the ability was handed down to him by his father
at first I thought it was a camera problem uh no
finally I was so frightened
I found Elise everywhere
new lion you're still afraid to
have your picture taken aren't you
one that can bring them back and
with what we saw tonight I would
say he doesn't have much time left to wait for you
a sound man by not advancing himself
stays the further ahead of himself
I have no idea what I'm doing
hahaha
let my voice
in a steady stride into the further
oh so scary
the younger version of him that's so creepy
foreign
don't mess with these weirdos
again tell me where my son is please
what
uh-uh
um
you're ugly
I think Dalton annoy the show just
be like Dalton Dalton Dalton Dalton
Blue's Clues Blue's Clues you know what to do
foreign
ER than they are Josh you are
the one alive get away from me
bye
baby Dalton Daddy oh God
oh my God daddy look I'm free okay okay
okay face me buddy face me come here
what
ah cats the amazing girl
he found your son
no not the lights stop stop stop stop
Daddy Let's
Josh follow my voice no better not be the woman
what
the hell Stephen Lorraine go check
on Dalton what go check on Dalton
what go check out Dalton now how many
times did she have to say it got two
crossing over no they're
not no no no no no no no no
no
please let him go you
oh no
um
what do you want from me what do you want from me
yeah [__] figure it out you can get away from me
get the hell away from me get away from me it's
not funny stop laugh why is everyone laughing
get the hell away from me
foreign wake up okay good poor baby
she's like bruh
I got some amazing shots
really hungry aren't you and I'm tired too
because you're tired I wouldn't go to
sleep I guess I don't need these anymore
what nothing I'm gonna get rid of these um
why did you do that why would you do that to
me when you know how I feel about that why
the science is it it's not him is it
nice
what
foreign
I'm right here
that ending it gave me chills
okay that was good that was good that was good I'm
not gonna lie I'm not gonna lie that was pretty
good listen I love me a good twist and at first
I was like this is like a homework ending like
how cute but I wasn't like mad about it because
I was happy to not be scared anymore but whoa
I like that ending that was a good ending I can
see why people said this was a really good movie
it keeps you on your toes it was a simplistic
plot yet visually it was really intricate the
acting was really good too the older woman she
killed it Elise was her name in the movie so
compelling she was awesome Dalton was really good
I mean the husband Chris Pratt like times 10 you
know what I mean it was scary but it was still
gratifying if that makes sense you know some
movies are just scary to be scary and you don't
feel like you walked away like connected to any
of the characters or like caring that much you're
just like what but like I really cared you know
little dolled in this movie seems iconic
in a way that I remember when it came out
everyone was talking about it and I feel
like for a horror movie to do that it's
kind of rare especially with all the CGI we
have and everything I think the last horror
movie that really made me feel some type of way
was hereditary and for some reason I agreed to
see that in theaters I don't know why and yeah
that was it was disturbing to say the least so
I feel like in terms of iconic you know horror
movies this definitely is in that uh category I
feel like because it was just such a talked
about subject when I was in high school and
still now you know like people refer to it
all the time like that red guy in Insidious
I get it that was a good movie because like I
would have been fine with the ending not having
that twist I would have been like still that
was like a movie but like that twist though
but now I feel so bad for him like go
get your husband like oh my God it's done
it was giving stranger things a little bit
but I think this came out before stranger
things but it's kind of an interesting like
similar concept except obviously the physical
body was still there well technically I mean
11 can like technically actual product in a
way interesting I felt validated watching this
movie because I did live in a haunted house at
one point and there were a few things that the
wife was feeling and going through that like I
went through and people will try to make you
feel crazy and they'll try to Gaslight you
but like trust your gut trust your instinct
I'm curious okay so now I remember watching
it being like how would they do a sequel you
know if they got Dalton if everything's fine
and now I really want to see the second one I
was sitting here like in the middle hating on
it I was like I'm not gonna watch the rest of
these but like should I it scared me it scared
me good it scared me good A lot of the shots were
really interesting obviously the first shot with
a lamp and then everything you know turning
up I down and I joked about the upside down
technically it's like a very similar concept so
the visuals were very good and if that red man bro
I don't like him okay I don't think anyone
should like him Darth Maul looking ass
it's funny I say that but I don't really like
remember those Star Wars movies and I don't
remember Darth Maul I've just seen him on like
everything Star Wars anyway the coloring in this
movie is really interesting for most of the
movie it's very Bleak not much color not much
saturation obviously with some Reds they pop out
but I found it interesting the saturation like
the color was super low kind of this like grayish
green color and then when he is in the further uh
the colors are way more saturated way brighter
they've got the bright red the bright teal
um stuff like that was really cool to see in the
further and it kind of definitely made you feel
like you were in a different world um so that was
a really interesting choice and I I enjoyed that
I don't like the people that were just standing
there staring I don't like them I think that they
shouldn't have been there just for my sanity it
was creepy I didn't get it I like it that room
I've had like a nightmare similar to obviously
like that room where people are just around you
and they're it brought back flashbacks you know
you have some nightmares that just stick with
you for your whole life that that's similar I've
had one of those also grabbing of the ankles and
yanking add one of those don't forget that it's
scary because I feel like some people can relate
to like having night terrors or sleep paralysis
nightmares and this reminded me a lot of that only
like times 10 this is like sleep paralysis turned
up to 11 not a fan not a fan of that I get it now
like I get why everyone's like oh my God it's so
scary and it's so good also I should mention I
totally forgot to mention this I remember I had
seen memes from this movie it was the the red
guy behind Chris Pratt 2.0 uh times 10. so I'd
seen that photo of that red guy and I remember
in high school people were like oh this is so
scary like of this dude now I know where that's
from and also the Tip Toe Through the Tulips
F that song I don't like it like I know that
song has existed before listening to me but I know
that this these kind of what made it popular for
like the horror genre I think anyways if you guys
want me to react to any more horror films please
leave a comment below if you want me to react to
the other Insidious movies let me know because
like now I'm invested I don't know if I can be
scarier than that but my God please give this
video a like if you enjoyed my reaction at all
give it a thumbs up share it if you think it's
funny like send it to someone again subscribe it's
free trick or treat subscribe it's a treat so I'm
gonna check uh it's night time now and I should
go to bed and I'm gonna say a long prayer tonight
it made me feel some type of way thanks again
for watching please subscribe to my channel I
put up a new Vlog for Halloween it's gonna be
up when this video is gonna be up and it's super
fun I actually get murdered in a Texas Chainsaw
fashion and I vlogged uh my experience on set so
it's super fun so I was also in a horror movie
but honestly this seemed creepy I feel like as
an actor if I was filming this I don't think I'd
have to act that much either in this because like
all those people standing there when he was
just with the lamp and then like getting her
ankles yanked and like even as an actor I feel
like this would be scary to do because I didn't
see a lot of CGI I saw a lot of people in like
practical effects which is awesome and like really
refreshing to see because they easily could have
done CGI with all this but I feel like I could
tell there were some shots with it obviously but
like I definitely could see that they use real
people for being ghosts and everything that
being said this is a classic and I see it I
get it I get the hype so anyway have a great and
safe Halloween please stay safe out there check
your candy don't drink and drive and have some fun
and with that being said I will see you next time